want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you two you have michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best believe life and get some
amazing motivation from the one and only
oprah winfrey enjoy
there's a bigger dream waiting for you
just waiting
for you
to step into it
to step into it your life is big
your life is huge and we spend so much
time
wanting to be in somebody else's life
and you don't get honored
you don't get revered you don't get
celebrating wanting what somebody else
has
because
that which created you divine
intelligence that dreamed you from
before
your ancestors ever knew
they would become your ancestors that
which dreamed the seed of you
wants you to know how special how
wondrous how mysterious how complex how
glorious how phenomenal you are
and you get no credit
messing in somebody else's territory
or trying to have
power
over something you have no control
another one of my favorite teachings is
the wizard of oz
when the wicked which is the west says
go away from here because you don't have
any power here you have no power in any
territory other than your own
oh but you are the master of that
you get to be the master of your own
fate you get to be the captain of your
own soul and if you just manage that
if you just took care of your territory
oh the glorious glorious glorious
wondrous
wondrous opportunities and possibilities
that are waiting for you so the question
is what are you resisting
what are you pushing against
what are you not allowing what are you
blocking because you have this idea of
who and what you're supposed to be
instead of
leaning into the dream that's already
been created and waiting for you it's
waiting for you and the second i mean it
doesn't it's an instant thing it's a
shift in the way you see yourself and
the power from which you have come you
see your life whispers to you all the
time if you're paying attention from the
moment you open your eyes in the morning
until the moment you go to bed at night
it's just speaking to you and really
hearing those whispers is one of the
most integral pieces of the puzzle i
believe that's needed to put together
the bigger picture
of your best life now there might be a
message sent or meant for you that first
comes in a whisper that to you sounds
like
hmm
that's strange or
oh that seems odd i didn't leave that
door open but then if that whisper isn't
addressed the whisper will become
amplified getting louder and louder
until it suddenly becomes what i call a
big thump on your head and if you're
still not paying attention that little
nudge transforms into a brick of a
problem and then eventually
all of those ignored bricks that make up
the structure and stability of your life
come crashing down so
know this for sure life is whispering to
you all the time
then turns into a brick of a problem you
ignore that problem you get a brick wall
of crises so the key is learning to get
the whispers
before they turn into bricks
so
this has shown up most often in my life
through relationships bad relationships
when i was younger when someone who's
shown me who they are in a whisper and i
keep hanging on until they do something
that's like a brick upside my head
so last year listen to this i toured for
wwe from january 4th to march 8th and
immediately after that last show i went
to the bahamas to take a week's break
and after two days i started feeling the
strong whisper just a feeling that maybe
i shouldn't be relaxing in foreign
waters and should get home
in case
our country went into some kind of
shutdown
literally at three in the morning that
feeling came over me
that i need to leave i need to get home
so
i returned home on march 11 stayed in
lockdown for the next 321 days and i've
learned over the years to kind of pay
attention and heed what twister bring
before it has to knock me upside the
head
so many things in life
like the pandemic are out of our control
but i do know that many things are in
our control
unless you choose to sleepwalk your way
through it so i ask you what is
whispering to you right now
some of you may have realized the life
you lived before the pandemic no longer
actually serves you and that returning
to working in an office is not your next
best move or maybe you gained a deeper
appreciation for your family and friends
or alone time as we talked about last
week you might even have turned a
passion or hobby into a full-on business
but there are others who are just gonna
get right back to their routine without
heaving those whispers and understanding
what is really calling to you if there's
one message you take away from me today
it's to listen to the whispers
because you are in the driver's seat as
to where
they leave you
so for the 25 years that i did the oprah
show i would often get frustrated
because some guests who would come back
and they just weren't paying attention
to their life
but i realized too it's easier to
observe it
it's often much easier to observe
someone else's situation more clearly
than your own so i encourage you to take
the time to observe and listen become
aware and learn to discern what your
head is saying versus what your heart is
saying and sometimes you may follow a
voice in your head that's not your true
calling and that's okay too because you
get as much from the losses as you do
from the winds
so i say
just keep
listening
being aware
of what is whispering to you now
all of you know the story of how this
great school came to be how the
stanfords lost their only child to
typhoid at the age of 15. they had every
right and they had every reason to turn
their backs against the world at that
time but instead they they channeled
their grief
and their pain into an act of grace
within a year of their son's death they
made the founding grant for this great
school
pledging to do for other people's
children what they were not able to do
for their own boy
the lesson here is clear and that is if
you're hurting you need to help somebody
else ease their hurt
if you're in pain help somebody else's
pain and when you're in a mess you get
yourself out of the mess helping
somebody out of theirs and in the
process you get to become a member of
what i call the greatest fellowship of
all the sorority of compassion and the
fraternity of service
the stanfords had suffered the worst
thing any any
mom and dad can ever endure yet they
understood that helping others is the
way we help ourselves and this wisdom
is increasingly supported by scientific
and sociological research it's no longer
just woowoo soft skills talk
there's actually a helpers high
a spiritual surge you gain from serving
others so if you want to feel good you
have to go out and do some good
but when you do good
i hope you strive for more than just the
good feeling that service provides
because i know this for sure that doing
good actually makes you
better so whatever field you choose
if you operate from the paradigm of
service
i know your life will have more value
and you will be happy
i was always happy doing my talk show
but that happiness reached a depth of of
a fulfillment
of uh of joy
that i really can't describe to you a
measure
when i stop just being on tv and looking
at tv as a job and decided to use t
television to use it and not have it use
me
to use it as a platform to serve my
viewers
that alone changed the trajectory of my
success so i know this that whether
you're an actor
you offer your talent in the way that
most inspires art if you're an anatomist
you look at your your gift
as knowledge
and service to healing the problem is
everybody is meeting hysteria with more
hysteria
and then we just are all becoming
hysterical and it's getting worse
what i've learned all these years is
that we're not supposed to match it or
even get locked into resisting or
pushing against it we're supposed to see
this moment in time for what it is we're
supposed to see through it and then
transcend it
that is how you overcome hysteria
and that is how you overcome
the sniping at one another the trolling
the mean-spirited partisanship on both
sides of the aisle the divisiveness the
injustices and the out and out hatred
you use it
use this moment
to encourage you to embolden you and to
literally
push you into the rising
of your life
and to borrow a phrase from my beloved
mentor maya angelou just like moons and
like sons with the certainty of tides
just like the hopes springing high
you will rise
i had a job until i could figure out
what it was really
what that gave my life its purpose and
meaning
and
i had gotten demoted in my job in
baltimore as an anchor woman because
as they hired me and then they decided i
was the wrong color
and i was the wrong size and i was the
wrong you know i had lots of problems
and they were trying to take me off the
air
and
um i was making 22 000 a year i thought
i was in heaven because i was making my
age and my dream at the time was gail
and i used to say can you imagine if
you're 40 and you're making 40 000 would
that be it
so um
uh that was as big as my dream was just
to make my age
and then i did this they they put me on
a talk show one morning because um
they didn't know what to do with me
and and i was interviewing the carvel
ice cream man it was a local talk show
and
um
benny from um
benny who was miss
chancellor's
uh butler or something on all my
children anyway my soap opera star who
wasn't the lead star remember benny
benny and the caraval ice cream men
that's how i cut my teeth and i finished
that show so it's not about the the
the stars themselves or whoever the
guests were but i felt like this is what
i'm supposed to do
all these years have been misplaced in
news because i couldn't relate to news i
was a news reporter and i'd be out on
the stories and i'd be crying with the
people
and i felt that i was exploiting the
people with news i couldn't
you know put a microphone in people's
face when they were going through
tragedies and stuff i just was so
emotional i was always getting little
notes from my boss about cut that out
you need to stop so but the moment i did
that talk show i felt like oh
i can be myself
and that was uh august 14th 1978 and
that was the beginning of fulfilling the
calling and so since that time
since that time august 14th 1978 i've
never had a problem with energy now when
i was working in news i used to be
exhausted all the time because i just
exhausted all the time because i hated
it
and the reason i didn't quit is because
i'm not a quitter number one and because
my father was like better not quit that
job you're making twenty two thousand
dollars a year
who's gonna play a black woman between
two thousand dollars a year you're never
gonna make it make that kind of money
again you better save half of it so
i i was reluctant to quit and think
about doing something else because i
thought okay
everybody wants to be an anchor woman at
the time that was like supposedly a big
deal being an anchor woman so i thought
okay i won't i'll just stay with this
until i can figure out what is the best
thing to do
and interestingly enough i was applying
for what i wanted to do
i felt like i needed to be able to talk
and at the time the only thing was
available was um
was uh like good morning america ortho
today show so i called up this agent and
i asked if he would accept my tape
because i wanted to be like a substitute
for brian gumbel and he said to me
there was only going to be one brian
gumbel and so
there wasn't going to be another one
that they weren't going to let another
black person on that show he said that
to me
and um interestingly enough he called me
last week because somebody else mentions
it to say he never said it but he did
say it and i said to him you know what
if you're ever told that you never
forget it if somebody ever says to you
if you're ever rejected in that way you
never ever ever forget it i said but
it's okay i did okay you did okay
it's all right but the answer to your
question is
if you can find what is your passion if
you find what you love you never get
tired or if you do get tired if you
you're fueled by the energy of your work
so i know that i'm doing exactly what
i'm supposed to be doing at this time
i also know that what the the show can
do
in terms of being
a voice and changing the world it's just
the beginning of what this show can do
it's fun to do things like this
but uh and it's necessary to do things
like this in order to be able to do the
bigger grander things to change what
happens to to the face of children in
africa for example what happens to
education with kids in in this country
so i believe that um
that what has happened to me is really
the beginning
of the greater passion to come
but if you find out what you're supposed
to do and you know what you're supposed
to do by how it feels
you know people wait on the voice of god
to be some the moses in burning bush i
think that was only bible talk
you know because he doesn't come to
burning bushes for people he comes
through your heart
he speaks to your heart through your
feelings and so you know what if you're
doing the right thing if it feels like
it's right to you and when you hit the
thing that feels right when you know
it's the right thing you would you know
it's right because it gives you your
juice
and you know it's right because you
would do it for nothing
you would do it for nothing and find a
way to be able just to do it
in order to be able to continue
that's how you know you're doing what
you're supposed to be doing so how do i
define success
let me tell you money's pretty nice
i'm not going to stand up here and tell
you that it's not about money because
money is very nice
i like money
it's good for buying things
[Applause]
but having a lot of money does not
automatically
make you a successful person
what you want
is money and meaning
you want your work to be meaningful
because meaning is what brings the real
richness to your life
what you really want
is to be surrounded by people you trust
and treasure and by people who cherish
you
that's when you're really rich i'm
content i'm not just relaxed i'm content
because i know a lot of rich people who
are not happy
but i am not one of them
but when you're i am one of the happiest
rich people you are ever going to see
when you're trying to just
when you're trying to get away from it
all and just get away from everything
you just relax at one of your homes or
yes i realize well and also it doesn't
take a lot for me to relax i can uh i
can be happy looking at a leaf gail will
say what are you sitting out under the
trees with your thoughts and i'll say
yeah i'm really i could be happy with a
book i can be happy reading poetry i can
be happy in front of a fire i can be
happy with my dogs i can be yeah
having compassion for other people is at
the top of that list
i would say commitment is at the top of
that list and also a spirit of
constructive engagement and by
compassion i don't just mean sympathy it
certainly isn't pity it's being present
and it's also
feeling with other beings you know
during the years of the oprah show i
interviewed over 37 000 people
one-on-one
so whenever i'm telling my girls
anything and they say uh they start
rolling their eyes like oh
i'm the only person you're going to talk
to talk to 37 000 people
so if i were you i would pay attention
but during all those years of talking to
over 37 000 people one on one
i could feel what they were feeling so
strongly sometimes it made me sick
literally
so i had to learn how to
feel how others were feeling feel with
others which
is which is what it means to be
compassionate to feel with others
without taking in all of their stuff
being compassionate means i feel
with
you
it is one of the greatest qualities in
the world to have if you're going to be
majoring
in what it takes to be a great human
being i feel with you
means i not only am willing to walk in
your shoes
it means my heart beats with yours
it means i see myself in you it means
i
may not have shared that circumstance
but i know what heartbreak feels like i
know what pain feels like and all pain
is the same
it means
i can feel your will to want to do
better and be better and i feel and i am
with you in spite of everything that's
happened to you
i
feel your need to rise i want to help
you rise i want to rise with you letting
go of energy that's clouding your vision
and holding you back
it's a life practice that i learned long
ago that has freed me
so many ways it's a fact that holding
grudges against somebody who's done you
wrong or
replaying revisiting hurtful situations
in your head over and over only weighs
you down and prevents you from being who
you're meant to be
right now because you're still
energetically holding on to the past the
energy that you put into constantly
rewinding to the resentment why did they
do that why did they say that to me i
didn't deserve to be treated that way
all of that only keeps you stuck
it will never change what happened
you gotta press stop
and reject the urge to keep replaying so
that you can then fast forward into the
now for yourself you know
a lot of people think
that holding on to things that
disempowered them
is going to somehow magically turn it
around
as i said in my message a couple weeks
ago about forgiveness
you have to release the notion give up
the hope that the past could have been
any different and you also must release
the idea that people would do what you
might do in any given instance this is a
big one i had to learn and relearn
before i actually got it expecting
people to do what you would do in a
situation only leads to your
disappointment not theirs they're going
on with their life so let people be who
they are and either you accept it or you
don't
not doing that keeps you stuck in a
circumstance that actually costs you
time cost you energy and i can guarantee
that oftentimes the person on the other
side of the bitterness you're holding on
to they're not even thinking about you
in fact they probably have just moved on
they certainly aren't obsessing the way
you are think of it like letting go of
any bad habit that just doesn't serve
your well-being
not an easy task
taking the road to a more enlightened
healthy existence never is so
this is what i want to ask you to ask
yourself
why am i holding on to this
how is this serving me
and really think about the answer
maybe it makes you feel validated maybe
it makes you feel righteous or maybe
taking on the pain is your way of
recognizing the injustice so that even
though it won't be made right
it can at least not be forgotten
then i ask you
again ask yourself
do you want to be right
or do you want peace
this was huge for me
the unfortunate fact is that having both
may not be possible and also you may
never get your moment of righteousness
so why wait for it choose peace
what i know for sure
is that in this world
time is a moving on and it's our most
valuable commodity you can never get it
back
so staying in that loop playing it over
and over in your head of hurt only
amplifies your pain let it go
exhale make room in your heart for
something that is uplifting
surround yourself with people who want
the best for you you have the ability to
shift the dna of your spirit and control
how you perceive life so why not lighten
your load and let it go the way to make
movies is to do stuff that you love
because you know for 25 years i worked
on the oprah show and
uh stephen will tell you that there were
day nights that i came home and i
almost you know it's hard to even like
take off my clothes because i knew i was
going to be getting up four hours later
but i never really felt exhausted
like deplet never i felt exhausted but i
never felt depleted so do the work that
comes straight from
the soul of you
from your background from stories that
you've grown up with from stories that
bring you passion from stories that you
uh not just yearn to tell
but that if you don't tell them they
won't get told and when you when you are
operating you know the single
the single greatest uh
wisdom i think i've ever received other
than when people show you they are is
that
the key to fulfillment success happiness
contentment in life
is when you align
your personality
with what your soul actually came to do
i believe everybody has a soul and has
you know their own personal
spiritual energy so when you can use
your personality to serve whatever that
thing is
you can't help but be successful so if
you do films that come from the interior
of your soul
you do work you do art that comes from
the interior of you
it you cannot miss
it's only when you're doing stuff that
you think might make money you think it
may be
a
hit or you think it may
uh bring you some level of attention or
success that isn't what does it i would
have to say that all of the great
wonderful experiences of my life that
have brought me to this moment have come
from working from the interior of myself
and so that's why it feels so authentic
because it
it actually is
so when you do that you'll win and
everybody has a different talent
and the reason we're all so messed up
is because you're looking at everybody
else's talent
and wishing you had some of their talent
all the energy that you spend thinking
about wishing about being jealous of
envious of anybody else is energy that
you're not only putting out is going to
come back to you negatively but you're
taking that away from you
all your energy should be forced on what
do i have to offer what do i have to
give how can i be used in service
because dr king's message of not
everybody can be famous but everybody
can be great because greatness is
determined by service and there is not a
job in here that you can do that you
don't switch the paradigm to service and
not make that job more fulfilling i
don't care what the job is if you say
i'm a singer i'm a dancer i'm an artist
i'm a teacher i'm a nurse i'm a doctor
i'm a janitor i'm a i'm a clerk
if you say if i look at this from how do
i use this in service to something
bigger than myself
it no longer becomes a job it becomes an
offering to the world this is the beauty
of of my life there's not a thing that
happens to me
that i don't look at it as a
teaching
learning experience and so whenever i'm
going into
any kind of crisis
i've said this many times before i'm
always looking for what is this here to
teach me for me colored girl negro child
growing up in mississippi
that one of the greatest gifts i was
ever afforded was not to have been put
in a segregated school system
had i been put in a segregated school
and taught in a segregated school system
that said you're less than because
you're a woman and you're less than
because you're a colored woman
i probably wouldn't be here today i
would have had to then overcome that
belief that conditioning of a belief but
because i was raised by a grandmother
who raised me in the church
and
i went to church
sunday school
lived in the church
and i would sit there
second pew on the right
third row
every sunday
just
taking it all in and i would listen to
the stories listen to the bible stories
and i would hear that through god all
things are possible
i would hear the story of jesus talking
about
if you have the faith of a mustard seed
and you know as many years later that i
actually
saw a mustard seed i could not believe
what a mustard seed actually looked like
have you ever seen a mustard seed here i
have some here
i want to pull one out now jesus said if
you had the faith of a mustard seed you
could move mountains
and anything was possible now i heard
this as a kid and i really believed it
and so the question is what do you
believe
do you believe that you are worthy of
happiness do you believe that happiness
success
abundance
comfort fulfillment peace
joy
love is a part of your birthright is
that what you believe
or do you believe something else because
you will
manifest
the life that you believe
i've always known that no matter what my
belief is i'm going to be all right why
because i have that faith of a mustard
seed empowerment is authority
it is a sign permission slip to actually
seize the day
it's the process of getting stronger and
more confident and more engaged and to
be empowered is to move through the
world without any kind of fear or any
kind of apology and with these gifts
comes an even deeper privilege i believe
and that is the ability
to take charge of your own life to own
yourself and claim your rights and
here's what i know for sure that to whom
much is given much is expected
and i have been given so much
i've earned it
i've been blessed with it
but i've been given a lot
and that's why i've chosen to use my
life to lift other people up nobody's
journey is seamless or smooth we all
stumble we all have setbacks if things
go wrong you hit a dead end as you will
it's just life's way of saying
time to change course
so ask every failure this is what i do
every failure every crisis every
difficult time i say what is this here
to teach me
and as soon as you get the lesson you
get to move on if you really get the
lesson you pass and you don't have to
repeat the class if you don't get the
lesson it shows up wearing another pair
of pants
or skirt
to give you some remedial work
and what i found is that difficulties
come when you don't pay attention to
life's whisper
because life always whispers to you
first first and if you ignore the
whisper sooner or later you'll get a
scream
whatever you resist persists but if you
ask the right question not why is this
happening but what is this here to teach
me what is this here to teach me it puts
you in the place and space to get the
lesson you need my friend ed cartoli
who's written this wonderful book
uh called a new earth
that's all about letting the awareness
of who you are stimulate everything that
you do he puts it like this he says
don't react against a bad situation
merge with that situation instead and
the solution will arise from the
challenge
because surrendering yourself doesn't
mean giving up it means acting with
responsibility
okay
many of you know that as president
hennessey said i started this school
in africa
and
i founded the school where i'm trying to
give south african girls a shot at a
future like yours stanford
and i spent five years making sure that
school would be as beautiful as the
students
i wanted every girl to feel her worth
reflected in her surroundings so i
checked every blueprint i picked every
pillow
i was looking at the grout in between
the bricks i knew every thread count of
the sheets i chose every girl from the
villages from nine provinces and yet
last fall i was faced with a crisis i'd
never anticipated i was told that one of
the dorm matrons was suspected of sexual
abuse
well that was as you can imagine
devastating news
first i cried actually i sobbed for
about a half an hour and then i said
let's get to it that's all you get is a
half an hour you need to focus on the
now
what you need to do now so i contacted a
child trauma specialist i put together a
team of investigators i made sure the
girls had counseling and support and
gail and i got on a plane and flew to
south africa and the whole time i kept
asking that question
what is this here to teach me
and as difficult as that experience has
been
i got a lot of lessons
i understand now the mistakes i made
because i
had been paying attention to all of the
wrong things
i built that school from the outside in
when what really mattered was the inside
out
so it's a lesson that applies to all of
our lives as a whole what matters most
is what's inside what matters most is
the sense of
integrity of quality and beauty i got
that lesson and what i know is is that
the girls came away with something too
they've emerged from this more resilient
and knowing that their voices
have power i have always known this
about celebrity
the real
power of being
somebody that somebody knows and i
really think that the only difference
between being famous and not is that
more people know your name
so the only difference
between understanding that
is understanding that what selma has
done what susan has done what anna has
done rebecca has done what jim has done
what i've done
you too can do
because true philanthropy comes from
living from the heart of yourself
and giving what you have been given
how will you do that
how will you use
your personality
the energy of your personality to serve
that which is your soul's calling
i know this for sure
any life no matter how fantastic it is
how glorious it seems how much attention
you receive how much square footage you
have
any life and every life is enhanced by
the sharing and the giving and the
opening up of the heart space
your life gets better when you can find
a way to share it with someone else
so what we've done you can do the real
empowerment comes when every person
leaves this room
and makes a decision
makes a decision
maybe that decision is that you will
write a check and support some of the
wonderful organizations you've heard
here today but the true decision is how
will you use yourself
how will you use everything that you
have been given
to serve that which is greater than
yourself
how will you use that to become
truly
authentically empowered
now
it is a beautiful thing to receive an
award and to be on the cover of variety
thank you very much
it's a beautiful thing
but the true reward is in the lives that
you are able to touch and the people who
you know you have impacted well you know
i managed to get here stedman and i have
absolutely uh differing philosophies
because he um teaches
um the idea of he has a book called um
not yeah what is a book called
the book is called you can make it
happen nine steps to success and he's
always um talking to me about cr having
a vision that would with no vision that
people perish and i always say i don't
have a vision i don't have a vision to
get here to where i am my vision was uh
surrendering to what i believe was god's
vision for me and i always say god can
dream a bigger dream for you that you
can dream for yourself i now believe
that i need a vision i think stedman is
finally right
that uh in order to continue to move
forward that i need to develop a vision
for myself and
one of my big goals is to use this
television show as a forum and a
catalyst for change in people's lives
that's one of them yes the other is to
move out into the world in a more um
impactful global format to help women
and children across the globe without
education the people perish without
education
nobody will be able to survive without
education women cannot overcome poverty
will not be able to learn to take care
of themselves will not be able to move
forward on the planet so i want to use
my life and this television show to
continue to do that you find that behind
the facade of all of your opinions and
your beliefs that at the heart of us
we all
want the same thing i want the same
thing that you want and i know that
whether you are republican or democrat
or libertarian or whatever you call
yourself that underneath every body is
this desire need to be valued and to
know that what you say what you think
what you want to do in the world your
fullest expression of yourself that that
thing matters i think some people think
that are under the impression that i was
born empowered that i was born
uh coming out of the womb ready to
interview a klansman
then cut to commercial we'll be right
back
but the truth is
i know very well what it's like to be
marginalized to be told either
subtly or quite directly that my
contribution
isn't or wasn't welcome
that my face was invisible and that my
needs were an affront so back when i was
doing the news in baltimore i asked to
be paid the same as my co-anchor who did
exactly the same job as i was doing
and
i
expected that i would be compensated so
i went in and i asked that i would get
the same amount of money so he was doing
the same job i was doing except that he
called me babe all the time babe yeah
babe
anyway i was told
by my news director and by the general
manager because first i went to the news
director then i'm a general manager and
i was told that because i was a single
woman
who didn't have a mortgage and i didn't
have kids that i was not entitled to
earn the same kind of money as the man
who was sitting next to me
doing the same thing
and i realized in that moment that my
employers did not get it they did not
understand my value
but you know what i did
so cut to am chicago the team's hard at
work and they had been working for a
long time
and after a year or so
we were asked to be syndicated
that work began to pay off and before
long we were now no longer called am
chicago we're the national oprah winfrey
show i got a raise this is before i own
myself
so i got a raise
but my producers did not so i went into
the boss at the time
and i asked that my producers who
incidentally were all female
i asked that they would be given a pay
raise increase
and my boss this is in 1986 said why
they're only girls
what do they need more money for
girls
uh i've used the word affectionately
sometimes referring to women as girls
and
there was no affection in his tone it
was absolutely condescending so
uh
you know it takes a while to develop a
voice
but once you have it you damn sure
better use it on stuff that matters
so i took a deep breath in that moment
and said
either they're going to get raises
or i'm going to sit down
i'm not going to work if they don't get
paid more
babe
now
i would like to believe that i could
have spoken that kind of truth to
misogyny even if i'd been all by myself
but here i was on the brink of finally
getting what i really wanted and had
been working uh many years for a
national show
i mean i might have been too intimidated
to stand my own ground against this guy
if i were actually alone but here's the
thing you're never alone
you're never alone
the sovereign sound of maya angelou's
voice
was pushing me forward that day
whispering
i come as one
but i stand as ten thousand
so when i was faced with the opportunity
to advocate for my producers
i silently called on some of the ten
thousand
and walked into my boss's office
hand in spirit
with the women who had come before me
i could feel bessie smith
and billie holiday and ella fitzgerald
and pearl bailey and sarah vaughan and
lena horne clutching their green books
looking for a place to eat while they
sang in supper clubs for whites only
and i could feel
reese taylor and rosa parks refusing to
relinquish their dignity in the face of
death threats all these women were with
me that day walking into the office in
chicago as was diana carroll and petula
clark and joan baez and mary tyler moore
and mom's maybelli and barbara walters
and all of the astonishing women
whose
names none of us will ever even know
despite their sacrifice
and i'm pretty sure
i even heard shirley chisholm
urging me on with this thought
if they don't give you a seat at the
table
bring a folding chair
and i understood
i understood that there were so many
times that many women from my mother's
generation and god knows my
grandmother's generation who were forced
to grit their teeth and just take it
because standing up for themselves
wasn't even an option
the risk was too great
and they knew it
but they also knew in their bones what
my dear friend maya
put so eloquently into words when she
says you may not control all the events
that happened to you
but you can decide
not to be reduced by them
because these women and so many others
like them made the decision not to allow
themselves to be reduced by the many
injustices they were subjected to i
found the strength to act if not just
for myself
not just for my producers but for all
the women who in their ingenious ways
subverted the rules
laid the foundation and pushed the
envelope just a little bit further for
me i know exactly the moment i started
to feel valued and for me it was school
i wanted to be a fourth grade teacher
because of mrs duncan and i haven't seen
mrs duncan since then and mrs duncan is
here today
the moment i felt the most of value
was
in my fourth grade class when mrs duncan
said to me
i i was the one who was chosen to lead
the class and whatever it was so what
was that like i don't i don't really
remember i do remember you that i
remember you was such a fluent reader
well if i had had a class full of
students like oprah i would have been
floating on air mrs duncan instilled in
me this
sense of
believing that i mattered
and that is what every human being is
looking for when you first heard that i
had like done something in life where
did you know that it was me yes i kept
it with you without your being aware of
it and it was mrs duncan who helped heal
you for me yes it was mrs duncan and
then it was my my sixth grade teacher mr
graham it was school that made me feel a
sense of value and connection
you learned a lot on this story oh i
learned a lot on the story the story was
life-changing for me life-changing
really life-changing people use that
word rhetorically
life-changing it's changed the way i
operate with
in my business with my people with my
school
one two three
you say that the most important question
to ask
of people who have gone through trauma
is not what's wrong with you
but what happened to you yeah yeah yeah
so when you see
you know a church being shot up or you
see you know all of the
headline making uh stories of people
seemingly gone mad your first thought is
what happened to that person right right
you know what has been life-changing for
me um is the question what happened to
you
not what is wrong with you but what
happened to you which is an important
question not just for people who have
been so-called traumatized but it's the
most important question you can ask of
anyone i can say
that of all the stories i've ever done
in my life and all the experiences i've
ever had and people i've interviewed
this story has had more impact on me
than
practically anything i've ever done
it's changed the way you see everyone
it's changed the way i see
everyone
so when i have an employee who is acting
out of line or who is just being a jerk
i don't think what's wrong with that guy
what's wrong with that girl what's wrong
with that bro i think i wonder what
happened to them
i wonder what happened to them i wonder
what happened that caused them to behave
that way that's what the story did for
me
for me
i've already made more money than i
expected i've already got more shoes
than i know
i'm like okay what to do with the shoes
you know so and it never was about
material possessions i don't think if i
could have um
if i'd sat down
and said how do i dream myself up to be
able to get all this i wouldn't have
known how to do it so i was driven by a
passion that was bigger than the show in
the beginning and i believe that in
order to continue every person has a
responsibility to use their life
you
everybody who came here today your life
may not be as big as mine meaning not as
many people know you and the only
difference between being famous and not
is that more people know your name the
real reality is what uh billy was
singing and what um maddie talks about
in his poetry is that we are really all
alike
except for our hair we are really
we are really all alike and that has
been one of the greatest lessons i've
learned in doing this television show is
that what everybody is looking for is
validation yeah in every experience
people are looking to know that they
matter that you matter that i matter and
every encounter in all of your fights at
home
all your arguments with your boss or
with your children with your husband
when you really peel back the layers and
get down to what is what is this what
are we arguing about you're arguing you
want to say i matter and i think that um
um
what we've been able to do on this show
is to help people see that for
themselves
and if i can be able to give that back
to people in a way that makes them
matter to themselves then this is worth
billions of dollars
it's priceless it's priceless to be able
to do that nobody's journey is seamless
or smooth we all stumble we all have
setbacks if things go wrong you hit a
dead end as you will
it's just life's way of saying
time to change course
so ask every failure this is what i do
every failure every crisis every
difficult time i say what is this here
to teach me
and as soon as you get the lesson you
get to move on if you really get the
lesson you pass and you don't have to
repeat the class if you don't get the
lesson it shows up wearing another pair
of pants
or skirt
to give you some remedial
work and what i found is that
difficulties come when you don't pay
attention to life's whisper
because life always whispers to you
first first and if you ignore the
whisper sooner or later you'll get a
scream
whatever you resist persists but if you
ask the right question not why is this
happening but what is this here to teach
me
what is this here to teach me it puts
you in the place and space to get the
lesson you need my friend eckhart tolle
uh who's written this wonderful book
uh called a new earth
that's all about letting the awareness
of who you are stimulate everything that
you do he puts it like this he says
don't react against a bad situation
merge with that situation instead and
the solution will arise from the
challenge
because surrendering yourself doesn't
mean giving up it means acting with
responsibility
okay
many of you know that as president
hennessey said i started this school
in africa
and
i founded the school where i'm trying to
give south african girls a shot at a
future like yours stanford
and i spent five years making sure that
school would be as beautiful as the
students
i wanted every girl to feel her worth
reflected in her surroundings so i
checked every blueprint
i picked every pillow
i was looking at the grout in between
the bricks i knew every thread count of
the sheets i chose every girl from the
villages from nine provinces and yet
last fall i was faced with a crisis i'd
never anticipated i was told that one of
the dorm matrons was suspected of sexual
abuse
well that was as you can imagine
devastating news
first i cried actually i sobbed for
about a half an hour
and then i said let's get to it that's
all you get is a half an hour you need
to focus on the now
what you need to do now so i contacted a
child trauma specialist i put together a
team of investigators i made sure the
girls had counseling and support and
gail and i got on a plane and flew to
south africa and the whole time i kept
asking that question
what is this here to teach me and as
difficult as that experience has been
i got a lot of lessons
i understand now the mistakes i made
because i
had been paying attention to all of the
wrong things
i built that school from the outside in
when what really mattered was the inside
out
so it's a lesson that applies to all of
our lives as a whole what matters most
is what's inside what matters most is
the sense of
integrity of quality and beauty i got
that lesson and what i know is is that
the girls came away with something too
they've emerged from this more resilient
and knowing that their voices
have power now before we came here
deepak chopra
great thought leader of our times i had
called him wanting to do an interview
with him and he said he was going to be
coming to india and i i i have a vision
board i keep a vision board first vision
board ever ever started was to get
barack obama elected so i just had
barack obama
and then i went back
and that vision board was right by my
in my bathroom by the bathtub so every
morning i would say barack obama
president barack obama
and then uh this is in 2007 and then i
decided i had to go back and put 2008 so
that whoever was listening would know i
didn't mean barack obama president
2012 or 2016. so i only had that as a
vision and then i put a picture after
barack obama one
i put a picture i cut out of a magazine
of a woman
on a camel
in and it said come to india
come to india
and i've held that as my vision
on my vision board
for the past three years so when this
idea of coming with deepak i went now
it's time to fulfill the vision so first
impression coming in the city chaotic
and then being in the city with
more people than i've ever encountered
in my life
but still feeling not a sense of being
unsafe if i leave you with nothing else
it's just know this for sure
there is not one
thing that has ever happened to you
not one experience
not one encounter not one crisis not one
joyful thing that hasn't
happened
just to make you better and help you
rise
every single thing you're calling in
whether you know it or not when you
figure out that you are calling it in
when you actually start meditating or
praying or doing or having a spiritual
practice which is the number one thing
you need if you want to be successful in
the world you need something that gives
back and nourishes you
regardless of what you call that you
need to you need to fill your cup so
that you can be so full your cup runneth
over and you have enough to give to
other people if you don't fill your cup
you end up dried up
you end up tired exhausted and don't
have enough to give to other people you
end up resentful every time somebody
asks you because your cup is empty and
now they want some of yours
so your number one job your number one
job is to fill
your cup
and
make yourself whole
that's your job you will find true
success and happiness
if you have only one goal there really
is only one and that is this
to fulfill
the highest
most truthful
expression of yourself
as a human being
you want to max out your humanity
by using your energy to lift yourself up
your family and the people around you
theologian howard thurman said it best
he said don't ask yourself what the
world needs
ask yourself what makes you come alive
and then go do that
because what the world needs is people
who have come alive
the world needs
people like michael stalzenberg from
fort lauderdale when michael was just
eight years old michael nearly died from
a bacterial infection that cost him both
of his hands and both of his feet
and in an instant this vibrant little
boy became a quadruple amputee
and his life
was changed forever
but in losing who he once was
michael discovered who he wanted to be
he refused to sit in that wheelchair all
day and feel sorry for himself so with
prosthetics he learned to walk
and run and play again
he joined his middle school lacrosse
team
and last month when he learned that so
many victims of the boston marathon
bombing would become new amputees
michael decided to banish that darkness
with light
michael and his brother harris created
mikeysrun.com
to raise one million dollars for other
amputees
by the time harris runs the 2014 boston
marathon
more than a thousand miles away from
here
these two young brothers
are bringing people together to support
this boston community the way their
community came together to support
michael and when this 13 year old man
was asked about his fellow amputees he
said this
first
they will be sad
they're losing something
they will never get back
and that's scary
i was scared
but they'll be okay
they just don't know that yet
we might not always know it
we might not always see it or hear it on
the news
or even feel it in our daily lives but i
have faith
that no matter what
class of twenty thousand
thousand thirteen you will be okay
and you will make sure our country is
okay
i have faith because of that
nine-year-old girl who went out and
collected the change
i have faith because of david and
francine wheeler i have faith because of
michael and harris stolzenberg and i
have faith because of you the network of
angels sitting here today one of them
khadijah williams
who came to harvard four years ago
khadijah had attended 12 schools in 12
years
living out of garbage bags
amongst pimps and prostitutes and drug
dealers homeless
going into department stores walmart in
the morning to bathe herself so that she
wouldn't smell in front of her
classmates
and today she graduates as a member of
the harvard class
of
2013. are you ready to allow abundance
and blessings people can't figure out
how i got to be so successful it is
because i have lived in the space of
spirit my whole life my favorite
bible verse because i am christian uh is
acts
something
i used to note a number but this is an
axe y'all can google it
but it says
thank you 17 28.
in god i live and move and have my being
i live and move and have my being and
you want to know why i am really so
successful i knew that at four years old
i knew that when my grandmother said you
better watch me now because one day you
have to learn how to wash these clothes
and hang them up like this so watch how
i hold these clothes pins in my mouth
[Applause]
and the reason i could do that is
because spirit
otherwise known as intuition
my instinct said
that's not gonna be my life
so we all have that spiritual side and
this lesson tonight is about connecting
to it i believe that beneath the surface
of all physical problems is a spiritual
solution there is a spiritual solution
why because you are a spiritual being
having a human experience that's the
beginning of understanding spirituality
you are a spiritual being
having a human
experience first law is
the third law of motion in physics which
says for every action there's an equal
and opposite reaction and we showed that
very beautifully in the color purple
when messily says to mister everything
you even try to do to me is already done
to you
that is not just a rhetorical saying
that is law that is newton's third law
of motion
in physics which says everything that
goes out
is coming back it's just like everything
that goes up is coming down may take a
long time to come down is coming down
everything that goes out is coming back
it's coming back so
to answer the power of manifestation and
meditation what meditation does is sync
you up with the source
what meditation does is allows you to
literally tap into the power that
created you so that you are in alignment
with that
and so when you carry that out into the
world everything that you do
comes from the center of that alignment
that's coming from the source that we
call god we call divine energy divine
intelligence whatever name you want to
give it we call life when you are synced
up with life
life just gives to you we
all are here to fulfill the dreams of
those who came before us
maya used to say you've been paid for
you've been paid for young people so put
your crown on your head and wear it
we are here not merely to bear witness
but to be the new voices of an
extraordinary new age you see when i was
growing up there were no black people in
the media just buckwheat
uh
on television and i was constantly doing
that thing looking to find myself and
what i found and said was leave it to
beaver and donna reed and lassie
although technically i guess lassie was
mostly brown
the the the point is though we are now
able to see ourselves reflected through
entertainment but what pleases me most
is that we're beginning to see
on screen
what we're beginning to see is starting
to change the landscape of what we see
behind the scenes what kamal was talking
about true inclusion and what i realized
during all those years during the oprah
show and the reason that own is now
thriving is how essential it is to see
yourself reflected in other people's
stories it's something that you as white
people never have to even think about
because the more you see a broader and
richer and more nuanced depiction of
yourself and your neighbor and the world
the more empowered you become and it's
that sense of empowerment that actually
tethers us to the universe it gives us
at least a glimpse of how connected we
all are
so what a blessed sign of progress it is
to know that millions of kids in 2019
don't have to stand with their noses
pressed up against the window or the
television screens looking in at a
family that makes them feel less than by
comparison today we can point to work
that says you are every bit as valued
and vital to the fabric of life as
anyone else you are a part of a
community but it takes time it takes
time to see yourself it takes time to
hear yourself and to feel to feel
appreciated for just being yourself
empowerment does not happen overnight
like change it is never just one thing
it is a series of consistent steps great
and small that proves to us again and
again that genuine change is actually
possible gwendolyn brooks wrote a poem
for her children it's called speech to
the young
speech to the progress toward and she
says at the end
live not for battles one
live not for the end of the song
live in the along
she's saying like art eckhart tolle that
you have to live for the present you
have to be in
the moment
whatever has happened to you in your
past has no power over this present
moment because life is now
but i think she's also saying be a part
of something
don't live for yourself alone
this uh this is what i know for sure
in order to be truly happy
you must live along with and you have to
stand for something larger than yourself
because life
is a reciprocal exchange to move forward
you have to give back
and to me that is the greatest lesson of
life to be happy you have to give
something back
so many people are worried about
building a brand i hear kids on social
media talking about their brand and i
used to really resent the word when
people would say to me oh you have this
brand because i never never even thought
about a brand i just thought about day
in and day out making the best right
choice for me
but now i embrace it because i recognize
people see me as a brand
but for me it's not a business it is a
question of what do you stand for
and i will say this you're nothing if
you're not the truth
so i have made
i've made a living
i've made a living i've made a life made
a fortune really it's fantastic
all good
from being true to myself
and that's the if i could leave you with
any message today that is it
uh the biggest reward is not financial
benefits though it's really good you can
get a lot of great shoes
nothing wrong with great shoes
but those of you who have a lot of shoes
know that having great shoes and a
closet full of shoes or cars or houses
or square footage doesn't fill up your
life
it doesn't
but living a life of substance
can
substance through
your service your offering of your whole
self and the baseline for how do you
live a life of substance is whatever is
the truth for you what do you stand for
people may not remember your every word
they may not remember all of your
actions but they certainly remember
how your words and your actions made
them feel
so let's leave here today
with the collective memory
of
wanting to create enlightenment in the
world
let's leave here
knowing that we can give people the
sense that they have been heard and
respected
let's foster original thinking
and humane treatment
let's seek out the words we don't know
let's do away with the us and them i've
seen us and them create a whole lot of
problems but i've never seen it solve
one thing
instead let's nourish our artists let's
offer the possibility of something
better
for all of us
because a new day is no longer on the
horizon
the new day is now if you can capture
the humanity of people
if you can just capture the humanity of
the people of the stories that you're
telling you then get that much closer to
your own humanity and you can confront
your bias and you can build your
credibility and hone your instincts and
compound your compassion
you can use your gifts that's what
you're really here to do
to illuminate
the darkness in our world there comes a
point
and i'm really i'm really good at this
is at not holding on to what was
and being able to live in this present
moment you know i never was one of those
women who's afraid to tell your age or
you're trying to be something you're not
i mean i think
for everything there's a time and a
season
the bible is
completely right about that i think i
think
and you know in your own self when it's
time to move from that my television
career began unexpectedly
as you heard this morning i was in the
miss fire prevention contest
that was when i was 16 years old in
nashville tennessee
and you had the requirement of having to
have red hair in order to win
up until the year that i entered so they
were doing the question and answer
period because i knew i wasn't going to
win in the swimsuit competition so
during the question and answer period
the question came why young lady what
would you like to be when you grow up
and by the time they got to me all the
good answers were gone
so
i had seen barbara walters on the today
show that morning so i answered
i would like to be a journalist
i would like to tell other people's
stories in a way that makes a difference
in their lives and the world
and as those words were coming out of my
mouth i went whoa this is pretty good
i would like to be a journalist i want
to make a difference well i was on
television by the time i was 19 years
old and in 1986 i launched my own
television show
with a relentless determination to
succeed at first i was nervous about the
competition and then i became my own
competition raising the bar every year
pushing pushing pushing myself as hard
as i knew sound familiar to anybody here
eventually we did make it to the top
and we stayed there for 25
years
the oprah winfrey show was number one in
our time slot for 21 years and i have to
tell you i became pretty comfortable
with that level of success i'm going to
continue developing shows that speak
to the humanity of people in a way that
makes them wanna
live better and do better
and um
that exalts their
their their victories and lets them know
that they are important and meaningful
in the world you know i would have to
say
that
every day david that show was such a it
was like therapy for me kind of like now
every day this show
was
i paid attention so i've never been to a
therapist but uh i i i paid attention
all those days on the show and i made
therapy acceptable for a lot of people
who thought uh not me not so
one of the things i started to get uh
around
mid to late no no mid to late 90s is
that everybody that i had on the show at
the end of the show would say something
to me like
um
was that okay was that okay how was that
was that okay right at the end of the
interview
and i started to then track it it didn't
matter if it was um i i had gone and
done a show where i was in
a prison i was interviewing a father
who
was in jail for life for murdering his
twin daughters and at the end of the
interview even behind bars he said to me
is that okay
how'd i do
and barack obama said it when he sat in
the chair the first time and george bush
said it beyonce said it at the end of
she taught me how to talk and then said
is that okay
so that's an acquired skill do you think
yes it's a working thing but this is
what i learned
uh sitting in that chair for 25 years
that at the end of the day
whether you are
interviewing me or i get to interview
you
whatever your profession is
wherever you are in your life in your
relationships
every person that you encounter every
experience the person wants to know
was that okay
was that okay
and what i started to hear was that what
people are really saying is did you hear
me
did you hear me
and did what i say mean anything to you
and so i started to listen
with that in mind with that intention of
validating that your being here
you're speaking to me you're taking the
time to do this with me is important
because you matter and that's true for
everybody who's watching or listening
that every argument that you ever have
every encounter the person just wants to
know did you hear me did you see me and
did i say anything
everything you try to do is already done
so when i figured that out oh what i'm
putting out is what's coming back
let me get real clear about what it is
i'm putting out
real clear
so
i read a book about 1989 called seat of
the soul and in that book gary zhukov
talked about
the laws
of karma of
the laws of cause and effect the third
law of motion and in that book he talked
about
how intention your intention
is always
one
with the law
meaning
before you even think about a thing you
have an intention for the thing
and that the intention is going to
determine the outcome
that's why the same people can go to the
same church service
and somebody walked down the aisle just
to be seen to put some money in
the
church
and somebody else who just goes and just
has a little bit to offer
the intention with which you give
the intention with which you serve
determines the outcome so when i figured
that out
i went whoa
i changed everything i did on my show i
called in the producers and i said from
this day forward i will no longer be
speaking to the kkk
i will no longer be speaking to people
who are fighting each other in a way
that it is damaging to the character of
myself and other people who watch from
this day forward i am only going to do
intentional television so when you're
saying i know who i am and i'm telling
you it's the thread that runs through
everything it's the thing that allows
you to stand in your own truth and one
of the things for years that maya
angelou used to say to me
is baby you need to know that you alone
are enough
you alone
are enough when i started the magazine
they said you will not see a profit for
at least the next five years and we were
profitable the first month the second
month and and
and have been since
and so i thought oh okay those
predictions that is not really not true
i had no idea how difficult it would be
however i am really um there's an old uh
spiritual that says wouldn't take
nothing from a journey now i really
was speaking to stephen this morning he
was saying it's a good thing that you
went through that because you were
living on the mountaintop for the past
25 years you created this machine of the
oprah show that it just felt like
walking into okay here we go so no
struggle no just it had become easy for
me to do so to be in a position to
build from scratch this network and to
go through everybody thinking it was
going to fail and there were days when i
had doubts myself like
i had to force myself to actually
practice what i had preached for years
about going inside staying with the
vision taking having every step move you
in the direction of the vision and
trusting trusting that building the
right team every single day
i would have a pre-show meeting
and have the producers come in and state
to me
what is your intention
how do we want to use whoever is on this
show
whatever is happening on this show to
serve the audience in a way that
fulfills the mission of uplifting
enlightening encouraging as well as
entertaining and if it doesn't do that
then i can't do it i can't put my name
on it i started feeling like i think
everybody knows
i've i've moved my whole life on
instinct you know i feel like now it's
time to
let the show go i feel like it's time to
move on because i've grown as much as i
can grow when i've grown as much as i
can grow in a space that's my instinct
to move i went through some tough times
after after i left the oprah show i made
a conscious decision
that i did not want to be sitting on tv
with the oprah show and y'all saying she
should have left that show
that show was really good two years ago
i made a conscious decision decision
that when i felt i had said
all that i could say and the audience
had heard it
that i would move on
and that i would not spend my life
regretting or trying to hold on to what
used to be or hold on to what i had so i
dreamed this dream
of starting a network
and in the beginning it was it was a
struggle
it was a struggle because
i didn't honestly goodness i did not
know what i was doing
i was trying to figure it out
i was trying to figure it out i thought
that the oprah show audience would
follow us to own then i realized y'all
didn't have cable
if you had cable you did not have the
own package
[Applause]
so
so it took me a minute
and unlike most people who you get to
have your mistakes in private some don't
go right in your life you get to
talk about it in private if i make a
mistake it's on the cnn crawl
or the cnn news so when i was in the
climb and there were so many wonderful
owners i see churro action jackson here
there were so many wonderful owners
people who said oh we're gonna stand
with you we're gonna stand by you thank
you roland martin there were so many
people who said listen we believe that
this can happen
so i dreamed the dream along with tyler
perry who was my friend who came to me
and said tyler
tyler said i'm going to help you out
because tyler can go home and write a
script and direct it produce it and
shoot it
and do it for less money than anybody in
hollywood so we started with the
foundation of having have not
[Applause]
if loving you is wrong
love thy neighbor
mama hattie
and then i started to dream another
dream about
scripted television because in the
beginning i was told you couldn't do it
you couldn't do it didn't have enough
money to do it
and
i dreamed the dream
i read proverbs 11 28 that says those
who trust in their riches will fall but
the righteous will rise and thrive like
a green leaf
it is your job
to make yourself whole
not perfect
but whole
and full
your world work in life
your real work is to fill yourself till
your cup runneth over
so that you're never grasping and needy
clamoring and insecure
but you can live your life assured in
your worthiness and your right to be
here and to become the best version of
yourself as a woman being most
embarrassing oh my god
my most embarrassing moment
was when the um
i told this on the tonight show once so
you've heard it you didn't hear it on
the tonight show you missed jay that
night my most embarrassing night when
the what was that the world soccer cup
thing came here dean world cup soccer
opened
here
in 19
was that 94
94.
cause you guys were shooting it okay
world cup soccer
i am asked to introduce i am the emcee
for the world cup soccer
okay
and i am coming out and i'd rehearse the
day before and i'd said to them you guys
have this plastic covering the stage
that is the same color as the stage so
you guys really need to change that they
did not so
the next day i'm on stage and i'm
introducing diana ross who's coming
across the other end of the field ladies
and gentlemen
diana ross and diana start i'm coming
out so she's coming across the field i
turned to walk off the stage
and fell in a hole
the hole that was covered with the
plastic i went straight through the
plastic
i went down in this big pit in the hole
fell scarred up my legs was bleeding and
couldn't get out but i could still hear
diana singing
so i'm in the hole the security guy is
going get her out get her up get on get
around
so
four guys they pick me up like this
spread angle and carry me out of the
hole
out of the hole i'm bleeding i go to the
other side they bandage my legs and i
limp back up
and i say
that was ross
the greatest lesson i've learned
throughout my career came from maya
angelou actually
when i was you know first meeting her
and uh
after i'd known her for a while she said
baby you know you need to know that when
people show you who they are
you believe them
the first time
oh you know that lesson too now
first time and uh your problem is it
takes you 29 times to see the same
lesson coming in a different skirt
wearing a different pair of pants so i
think that has been one of my
greatest wisdom teachings is to
assess
from people's behavior their actions not
just towards me but towards other people
uh who they are and how they behave
because if people talk about other
people they'll talk about you so i think
in business and in personal
relationships that's also been my
greatest lesson the challenge of life
i have found is to build a resume
that doesn't simply tell a story about
what you want to be
but it's a story about who you want to
be it's a resume that doesn't just tell
a story about what you want to
accomplish but why
a story that's not just a collection of
titles and and positions but a story
that's really
about your purpose because when you
inevitably stumble
and find yourself
stuck in a hole
that is the story that will get you out
what is your true calling
what is your dharma what is your purpose
and i would say reading
is the strongest
signal for success in the future that
i've ever seen it is the strongest
strongest strongest i got my first job
in radio
uh when i was 16 years old because i've
been broadcasting since i was 16 years
old but my first job i got because i was
a great reader when you are a great
reader you can articulate and speak
and command the english language in ways
that other people cannot and people
think you're a lot smarter than you are
lots of times because you're a great
reader have you ever met a person who
was a great reader when they were young
who was not successful
you never never it is the absolute best
foundation ever
in life the reason why i was number one
for 25 years
is because i figured out early on
there is no story anybody has ever heard
that somebody else hasn't experienced
nothing
and i also figured out um probably maybe
the first or second year
that all pain is the same
that a mother in somalia feels the same
way as a mother in seattle when she
loses her child
and
the common denominator in the human
experience
is our emotions and our feelings
and the more vulnerable and open you are
willing to be with your story the more
actual understanding you create with
other people and the more powerful you
become people don't think less of you
for sharing your story they think more
of you for having the courage to share
it the biggest transformation for me was
living my life with intention you know
what i know i live by this law of that's
the third law of motion physics which
you put out is coming back but before
you even put it out you have an
intention and so to have a clarity of
intention about what you actually want
to do and why you want to do it is the
most important thing and then to just
set that vision and have every step you
make move you in the direction of that
vision it doesn't mean that every day
it's going to happen some days you're
off track like i intended to work out 45
minutes i only got in 37 this morning
well that's better than two it's better
than zero and that's that's that's
that's what i said okay at least you got
some movement in and i'll go back and
i'll make up the other eight later but
i think you just made it up
actually as i was walking i think i
think this is gonna be eight minutes i'm
gonna make it up so uh it's it's about
it's daily renewal it's not one big
gigantic goal it's everyday
coming back giving yourself the
opportunity to get it right because
that's what every sunrise means it's oh
gosh it's another chance to get it right
it is yeah there has to be some way
that this darkness
can be banished with light
says the man whose little boy
was massacred on just an ordinary friday
in december
so whether you call it
soul or spirit or higher self
intelligence
there is i know this there's a light
inside each of you
all of us
that illuminates your very human
beingness if you let it and as a young
girl from rural mississippi i learned
long ago that being myself was much
easier than pretending to be barbara
walters
although when i first started because i
had barbara in my head i would try to
sit like barbara talk like barbara move
like barbara and then one night i was on
the news reading the news and i called
canada kanada
and uh
that was the end of me being barbara i
cracked myself up on tv
couldn't stop laughing and my real
personality came through and i figured
out oh gee i can be a much better oprah
than i could be a pretend barbara what
would you say to your younger self oh
honey honey honey
oh baby girl
what the world has in store for you
first of all would be relax
it would be
stop being afraid
and it would be everything's going to be
all right no matter what you're going to
be okay i did this movie called their
eyes are watching god and i was an extra
and and it was a movie that oprah was
producing and she had walked by and i
was making all the other extras laugh
and stuff i was telling jokes and she
she's like you're a very funny young
lady i was like
and she was like what's your name i said
my name is tiffany haddish and i'm a
stand-up comedian and she said well keep
me up to keep me updated on your career
write me let me know what you got going
on i love comedy i said oh yeah i know i
know i heard and so i would write her
right right and i never got any nothing
and i think it's because it was a lot of
misspellings or something because you
know i wasn't a good reader at that time
so definitely not a good writer i'd say
but um i'm better now well she never
wrote back i wonder why let's ask her
why she didn't write back oprah why
didn't you write back
[Applause]
[Applause]
so this is a deal i love you
you are so
so so good
you are so so so come on you told me
that before in a dream you know it's
true
dr king said not everybody can be famous
and i don't know if everybody everybody
today
seems to want to be famous but fame is a
trip
people follow you to the bathroom
listen to your pee
just
try to pee quietly it doesn't matter
they come out and
say oh my god it's you you peed
that's the fame trip so i don't know if
you want that
so
dr king said not everybody can be famous
but everybody can be great because
greatness is determined by service
yet those of you who are history
scholars may know the rest of that
passage he said
you don't have to have a college degree
to serve
you don't have to make your subject and
verb agree to serve you don't have to
know about plato or aristotle to serve
you don't have to know einstein's theory
of relativity to serve you don't have to
know the second theory of thermodynamics
and physics to serve
you only need a heart full of grace and
a soul generated by love i have a very
big life
and so people with big lives can do big
things and so i started to think about
what was the best christmas i ever had
in my life i grew up poor
uh on welfare with my mother for part of
my life
and i remember that the best christmas
of my life was when i was 12 years old
and
my mother had said
we're not gonna have christmas
because we can't afford it
and my feeling at the time was okay well
so that runs that's santa claus bit
it's 12 that's when i realized there was
no santa claus because now he ain't
coming because we're poor
and uh
i remember feeling like
it's going to be really hard on
christmas morning to go outside
everybody had you know you go outside
with your toys what am i going to do
when everybody else is outside
that's what i thought what am i going to
do when everybody else is outside and
what am i going to do when i have to go
back to class and say i got nothing so
that's what i was mostly worried about
and then some nuns showed up
some three nuns came to our house and
they gave me a doll and they bought us
food and we had our christmas that was
the best christmas of my life because
somebody remembered and i wasn't going
to have to be
the kid that said i got nothing so i
wanted to be able to create that same
feeling
for
children who had nothing
so i decided to go to south africa
originally i wanted to do a million kids
because i thought we can do a million
kids
and then just realize with i only had uh
four weeks vacation so in four weeks i
could not reach a million kids because i
didn't want to just write a check
send a donation i wanted to be able to
look in each kid's face and say to that
child somebody remembered you and so
that's what i did with my life this
christmas i took 41 people from here
hired another 50 people over there and
we were traveling caravan from one
village to the next we did 2 000 kids a
day we had
parties for children who were orphans
and it was singularly i will tell you i
could weep thinking about it the
singularly the best experience of my
life
the singularly best experience of my
life the first day in africa where we
had um
three 280 kids in a room and every
single one of those kids had lost a
parent
every single one of those children they
were aged 3
to 17 in that room and my team that
you're talking about i have the greatest
team in the world my team in here in the
united states had been in contact with
the orphanages so that by the time we
got there
we had a present with every child's name
on it
i had um
uh
this summer
every black doll manufacturer in the
country had sent me dolls because i
these girls had never seen black dolls
and so it was my mission to do for them
what the nuns had done for me was to let
the african girl see a black doll so i
wanted every girl to have a black doll i
wanted every boy to have soccer balls we
bought radios we bought clothes and the
most important thing is we had their
names on every box for every child
and i called up the children one by one
and when those children
you know received their gifts and then
waited for the next child to receive
their gifts and said
i said nobody can open their presents
until everybody can open their presents
and on the count of three when i counted
the three and those children open their
presents was the single greatest moment
of my life
and i share that with you
i share that with you
because that's what i can do i can be i
have a big life so i can take 50 000
presents and do that over and over and
over again to orphanage effort orphanage
but what i felt in that room for those
from those kids
is a lot of what you're talking about
and what you're talking about and what
you see in the faces of those women when
you look into the eyes of someone
and you give them a gift whether that be
a physical gift or it'd be a gift from
your
spiritual self from your presence from
the essence of you and you see the light
you see the joy what i felt in that room
was not just that i was remembered that
that the child felt that i was
remembered but you felt a sense of hope
a sense of validation a sense of
validation that somebody cared about me
and i will tell you that
of all the years and shows that i have
done
and every theme for every show that i've
done
the single common denominator
denominator that i found that every
human being is looking for is validation
every single person needs to know
wants to feel that they matter
that they matter and what happened in
that room that was the greatest day of
my life i knew that those children knew
in that moment that they mattered that
they mattered and so i encourage you
it's exciting to be able to write a
check
it's even more exciting to be able to
touch one life
to be able to do that for one person
it's like cynthia was saying when you
can do that for one person when you can
do that you will know that your life has
meaning and i will tell you when i left
that place my friend gail and i were
there and we're all boohoo and we're
like boom with the children oh my god
and gayle was saying what is it what is
it we're so full as gail said to me she
said you know as big as your show is as
big as your show is what happened in
that room seemed bigger
what happened in that room sing bigger
and that is true that is true for me who
has this big life and a television show
and i'm telling you for everybody here
extending yourself beyond your world
your kids your family your stuff and
reaching out to somebody who is not like
you somebody who is like you who is
indeed if you are feeling depressed or
you are feeling down or you're feeling
like things aren't going the way you
want them to go in your life the way you
turn that around is to reach outside of
yourself to somebody else reach outside
of yourself to somebody else it will
change you
it will change you
i don't make resolutions anymore i have
a word so at my dinner table we all go
around the table and we say what's your
word for this year okay and my word is
purpose
my word for this year is purpose because
when i look back on my you know how you
can't even figure out what you did in a
year because your life's so full yeah so
another now i just go back and i look
through my phone so i was doing that on
new year's eve looking through the phone
and all the pictures all the stuff
you've done and i did a lot of things
but i didn't do a lot of things on
purpose with intentional purpose so my
thing this year is don't do anything
unless you have an intention and a
purpose behind it so it is my intention
my intention
to fulfill the dream of the creator
it is my intention
to live to the highest calling and be
pressed to the mark of the highest
calling that i have come to do and when
you can ask the creator
ask that which made you you
what is your dream for me
i guarantee you instead of you trying to
define the dream what is your dream for
me
if you're able to lean
into the dream
that the universe and all the forces of
of of of light and love and power and
grace by all the names that we call god
has for you
nobody can touch you
nobody can touch you
that show was on for 25 years in chicago
and um when you did it you won i think
almost 50 emmy awards and it was voted
one of the best tv shows in the history
of tv so you ended it though after 25
years to do other things and we'll talk
about that but no regrets about ending
that show no no we got no regrets
whatsoever you know i i didn't want to
be punch drunk in the ring still trying
to
uh
come up with what is the next thing what
is the next thing because over the years
we became our own greatest competition
so when i first started uh went national
in 1986 every time there would be
another talk should be oh geraldo rivera
oh what are we going to do and then i
realized a couple of years in that you
run your own race better than anybody
if you take the time to see what
everybody else is doing you lose your
ground and that i could be a better me
than i could be anybody else and so no
need of trying to compare myself to
other people one of the things i tried
to do all those years on the oprah show
sometimes people would criticize me
because i felt that i didn't do enough
for race or racism but this is what i
always understood
that
for me
my role
and my goal in life
is to open this open people's hearts
that's what i do is i i try to tell
stories that allow people to see
themselves and the lives of other people
and for me it was always more
powerful and effective to do a show for
example on
single parents raising their children
and
just on the panel of parents to have a
black father
and to show the photographs or images of
that father putting his child to bed and
reading a story at night
that to me is more powerful than doing a
story on let's talk about uh fathers
black fathers who are raising their
children because the goal for me
is to show that we are all more like
than different and that in in our
humanity
in our ability to express our humanness
we are the same so when you see
a father putting his child to bed at
night and reading stories and that man
is black and you know that's what your
husband does and that's what you do you
you feel a sense of connection and
humanity one of the things i started to
get
uh around
mid to late no no mid to late 90s is
that everybody that i had on the show at
the end of the show would say something
to me like
um was that okay was that okay how was
that was that okay right at the end of
the interview
and i started to then track it it didn't
matter if it was um i i i had gone and
done a show where i was in um
a prison i was interviewing a father
who
was in jail for life for murdering his
twin daughters and at the end of the
interview even behind bars he said to me
is that okay
how'd i do
and barack obama said it when he sat in
the chair the first time and george bush
said it beyonce said it at the end of
she taught me how to talk and then said
is that okay
so that's an acquired skill do they yes
it's a working thing but this is what i
learned
sitting in that chair for 25 years that
at the end of the day
whether you are
interviewing me or i get to interview
you
whatever your profession is
wherever you are in your life in your
relationships
every person that you encounter every
experience the person wants to know
was that okay
was that okay
and what i started to hear was that what
people are really saying is did you hear
me
did you hear me
and did what i say mean anything to you
and so i started to listen
with that in mind with that intention of
validating that your being here
you're speaking to me you're taking the
time to do this with me is important
because you matter and that's true for
everybody who's watching or listening
that every argument that you ever have
every encounter the person just wants to
know did you hear me did you see me and
did i say anything that mattered and
this is the thing i think i have to just
say
everybody is feeding yourself on
the hysteria and the negativity you
gotta stay in the light but one of the
reasons why i was so excited is about a
wrinkle in time because the message is
that the darkness is spreading so fast
these days
you must become a warrior of the light
and the reason that's so meaningful to
me is because that's how i've led my
whole life and every moment in that film
i just felt like i'm just saying what
i've normally said it's true
and and for these times the darkness is
there to show you your light look at
what has happened so if you put the
focus on look at what happened with the
darkness that showed up in parkland and
the darkness that showed up on the
streets of ferguson the darkness that
showed up in many many many many many
many homes in chicago with shootings and
uh senseless murders it brings out the
best in people it brings out the best
and so that's what it's there we live on
a planet where there is darkness and
light i teach them that there is no life
without
cultivating a spiritual life
because you are first and foremost a
spiritual being having a human
experience
and if you lose sight of that
it's easy to get lost in the world
and no one can save a world that they're
lost in when they've lost sight of their
own north star
so having a spiritual life actually
means actively and ritually creating the
space in your life
all the time for gratitude for kindness
for empathy for inspiration for joy and
for reverence for life
in the home of your soul first
and then working to spread that inner
joy outward it means
slowing down it means taking in the
moment it means being exactly where you
are
not distracted somewhere else it means
knowing who you are and getting about
the business of fulfilling why you
really came to our planet you came from
very modest circumstances you didn't
come from a wealthy family well modest
is not the word well i was trying to be
polite i was i was actually
poor and i you know a lot of the girls
at my school actually all the girls from
my school are poor and i was saying to
them just recently i was just in south
africa for graduation you know you all
are comf come from the same
circumstances you were poor and one of
the girls raised their hand and said i
don't like using that word i go well if
you're not poor then you should excuse
yourself because that's why i'm paying
for you because you're in my school so
if you're not you don't like the choice
of the word so i don't i don't have a
problem with the word i don't have any
shame about it i think you know probably
earlier in my
life or career the word would have
bothered me but it truly it was it was i
was poor no running water david or
electricity
living with an outhouse
okay that's poor you can't get what you
want by focusing on what you don't want
this is about the need to
establish
as many meaningful connections as we can
if we're going to save the world we have
to find a way to connect to each other
to connect to the nature that we're
killing to animals to history to an
acknowledgement of the lingering trauma
of racism and sexism we need to connect
to the people we love and mean something
to us and more than that to the people
who don't
that doesn't mean we always have to
agree with another person's philosophy
it means
we if we're going to continue to survive
and thrive on this planet have to find
ways to transcend the politics of
division and embrace the places that
bond us where we find our human ground
everybody works hard
and everybody has their own dreams
there is
there was a time
where i used to spend a lot of energy
wanting things
wanting things
of course it's easy for me to say oh
things don't define you because i got a
lot of things things nice i like them
but this is what i learned
when you can surrender to the dream
you get to live in the space of the
higher power
you get to live in the space
that you purposefully have come to earth
to claim for yourself so
around 1984
i was sitting in bed one morning
uh sunday morning should have been in
church but i wouldn't
i was reading
the new york times review of the color
purple
and i thought whoa this sounds like a
really great book i got out of bed in my
pajamas put on my galoshes
and
went to the store to get the copy of the
color purple
i read the color purple in one afternoon
got
went back to the bookstore bought every
book of the color purple i took the
books to the office and i said to
everybody y'all got to read this book oh
my god you got to read this book color
purple i needed a book club i didn't
have one
so i pass out the book to everybody i
knew please read the color purple read
the color purple
then i start to hear
that somebody's gonna do a movie about
the color purple but i don't know
anybody in the movie business by this
time i was on am chicago i don't know
anybody i start praying to god god
please help me find a way to get into
color purple
i say jesus i don't even have to have a
speaking part
i will be because i went to the movies
and i saw on the movie credits
at the last credit there's something
called best boy
so i said jesus if you just let me be
best girl
that'll be all right by me i can be best
girl i can carry the script i can help
the people with the water i can do
whatever so i start praying for the
color purple
as
as
divine law would have it quincy jones
comes to chicago
and he is in chicago for one half of a
day
because somebody has filed a suit
against michael jackson claiming that
billie jean was their lover and that's
not his song
so quincy had taken the red eye to
chicago
he was in his hotel room
he was coming out of the shower
and the television in his hotel room is
on am chicago
there sits
little chubby me
with my jarrett curl
on am chicago
quincy jones tells ruben cannon the
casting agent i think i found
sophia so i get a call
from ruben cannon who says i'm calling
about a movie
it's called moon song
would you be interested to come and
audition and i say i have not been
praying for moon song
no
i had not been playing for moon song
i've been praying for the color purple
he said well
i think you should come and and audition
so i go to audition you know movie
people they make everything all secret
steven spielberg didn't want anybody
know he was doing color purple so on the
outside of the script it says moon song
but i know all the words by heart
so when i open the script i know this is
the color purple jesus this is the color
purple
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
so i auditioned for the color purple i
can't even believe it they don't just
want me to be the water girl
or the best girl they are asking me do i
want a part in the movie oh that i'm
thinking prayer prayer works
prayer works
but listen to this
three months pass three months is a long
time
i auditioned in february
march
april may comes i haven't heard anything
so i call reuben cannon
i say mr cannon
i'm sorry sir i haven't heard anything i
expected to hear something by now and
reuben cannon
african-american man
says to me
you don't call me
i call you
and i didn't call you
do you understand that i have real
actresses who have auditioned for this
part
real actresses and he tells me who just
left his office and i went well okay i'm
not getting that part
so i hang up the phone and i start
crying
i can't believe that god has played this
trick on me i think
this is a trick
so i decide that this is because the fat
has finally caught up with me
the fat has finally caught up with me
and now i must get rid of the fat
in two weeks
i am going to go to a fat farm
and i'm going to lose
25 pounds
i'm gonna drink a lot of green juice
i'm gonna have some cleanses and
colonics
so i i also
was trying to make peace with it
i said god
i don't understand
i thought it was for me you ever had
that talk with god
i i thought it was for me i thought it
was for me
god you let me audition with somebody
named harpo
that's my name backwards jesus that was
a sign wasn't it a sign
and then three months pass and then then
reuben cannon says real actresses
have just left his office
so i start to pray on the track i'm out
on the track
at the fat farm
and i am running around at the track
at the fat farm
it starts to rain
y'all know how that is
but i don't even care cause i am praying
to god to help me to let it go
help me let it go because now i've
become obsessed with it and it's now
controlling my life i start praying
running around the track
and i keep hearing this noise and i i
can't there's nobody on the track but me
and i'm running around the track
and i look around and it is my thighs
rubbing together
it's my thighs
my thighs are rubbing together
causing this thunderous sound
there's nobody on the truck so then i
really start to cry
oh lord help me
help me let it go help me let it go help
me let it go god help me let it go
and you ever did this prayer where you
say okay lord don't come and let it go
then you get up and you go well i think
i still got a little bit of it
i did help me let it go
but i am not going to be able to see the
other actress in my part i won't be able
to see it won't be able to see color
purple just can never see it the rest of
my life i won't be able to see it
so then i started
i don't know where it came from
i surrender all
surrender all
all
to thee my
blessed savior
i
surrender
all
i sang and i cried
i sang and i cried and i prayed some
more
until
i could reach the point where not only
not only will i be able to go to the
movie but i can bless
the other actress
i can bless her
i can say
i bless you i bless you i bless you with
this i surrender all
i
surrender all
all
to thee
my
blessed
savior i
surrender all
and i tell you
in my greatest testimony
that the instant i laid that thing down
i'm telling you when i laid it down
when i laid it down and it didn't have
me anymore
it had no control over me anymore
i didn't feel anything about it anymore
when i let it go
when i intentionally surrendered it to
the power that was greater than i could
ever know the instant that happened
a woman comes running out of the
cafeteria
screaming offering
is your name all free
for 10 years nobody can pronounce my
name
i said yes she said somebody's on the
telephone for you he's a named spielberg
i get to the phone
he says i hear you're at a fat farm
i said no sir
this is a health retreat
he says i'd like to see you in my office
in california tomorrow this was in
wisconsin i was i'd like to see you in
my office
and if you lose a pound
you could lose this part
[Applause]
no problem do i have
i'll have no problem not losing a pound
so honey i packed my bags
and i stopped at the dairy queen
[Applause]
i got three scoops just in case i'd lost
a half a pound
and the next day i was in steven
spielberg's office and he said you're
hired you're hired oprah i'm dying to
know what is in your purse
i'm not quite sure myself
okay so somebody's gonna bring out my
purse
this is this is kelly hurliman who
dresses me every day so this is this
this is uh
who did it who did a real good job today
except i said to her i think these boots
are size nine
and i wear a size 10. they look so cute
though but i look cute but damn my feet
hurt okay
okay hey no no kelly just stand here i
don't know this is the bag i was
carrying this morning it was right
where'd you find this
boy upstairs in the closet on the table
on the table okay this is what's in my
purse right now
um
okay so there's my little makeup bag
okay that's cute all in one bag
this was given to me by nate burkett
uh then there's
that there's my there's my wallet
there's my um
blackberry
the color purple uh y'all should go see
that i saw that the other night
now
these are the sunglasses ellen i carry a
black pair and a brown pair because you
never know what you're going to be
wearing
this is uh contact lens cleaning fluid
this is uh
uh
charger for my blackberry uh
this is a movie freedom land
this is a uh oh this is great this is a
poem my angela just is gonna do the
white house
and uh okay what is this
oh this is uh
this is uh this is my angel's itinerary
so i know where she is
and uh that's about it okay what i would
like to know is oh got some pins down
here
and some glasses reading glasses and i
got um
sophie's balls just whenever we're
playing
she only likes the clear ones
and uh that's it okay let's see how much
money do i have my wallet
okay got receipts i keep those for you
when i was shopping the other day
then again this is how much i got pull
out all my money here we go
yeah i have a wallet
i have south african rans
ran
and hold on
two dollars
[Applause]
it's bad
wait a minute oh oh no there's more
there's more money okay there's more
there's more money there's 10
11 12 13. 14
it doesn't matter how far you might rise
at some point
you are bound to stumble because if
you're constantly doing what we do
raising the bar
if you're constantly pushing yourself
higher higher the law of averages not to
mention the myth the vigorous uh
predicts
that you will at some point
fall
and when you do i want you to know this
remember this
there is no such thing as failure
failure is just life trying to move us
in another direction now when you're
down there in a hole it looks like
failure
so this past year i had to spoon feed
those words to myself
and when you're down in the hole when
that moment comes it's really okay to
feel bad for a little while
give yourself time to mourn what you
think you may have lost
but then here's the key
learn from every mistake
because every
experience encounter and particularly
your mistakes are there to cheat you and
force you into being more of who you are
we have to make the choice every single
day to channel our own inner jucindas
to exemplify the truth
and the respect
and the grace
that we actually wish for the world
we need to tell it as we're doing at
this conference we need to write it
we need to sing it
we need to proclaim it
we need to be it we need to be the truth
we have to be the respect we have to be
the fierceness the love that we want to
see
and when we do that mark my words a
change is already
coming i wake up in the morning what you
do and the first thing i say is thank
you
that's my first thing
even before i'm awake even before my
eyes are really fully open i i say thank
you i can feel the gratitude like i'm
still here i'm in a body thank you so
much i thank you for that and then i go
through the letting the dogs out the
whole you know brushing your teeth and
all that stuff and then i have either
silence or prayer or something that
acknowledges that i'm still here i do
not reach for that phone first that's
your problem
that's your problem you have no idea the
power
of
noticing
another human being
and what it feels like when somebody
knows that they have been seen truly
seen by you
it is the greatest offering you can give
and all those years of the oprah show
the greatest lesson i learned was that
you know after every show
uh someone would say invariably in one
way or another um
how was that i finished an interview
with father who killed his twin
daughters i'd finish an interview with
politician barack obama joe biden george
bush that beyonce they all say the same
thing
how was that
and so i started to see that there's
this common thread in our humanity
where everybody wants to know
how was that
did i do okay
did you hear me
and did what i say
mean something to you
so i would have to say that
recognizing that in other people has
helped me to become you know a person of
compassion a person understanding a
person who can interview anybody about
anything because i know that if the core
of you is the same as core me you just
want to be heard i know you all
understand better than most that real
progress requires
authentic
an authentic way of being
honesty and above all empathy
i have to say
that the single most important lesson i
learned in 25 years talking every single
day to people
was that there is a common denominator
in our human experience
most of us
i tell you we don't want to be divided
what we want the common denominator that
i found in every single interview is we
want to be validated
we want to be understood i've done over
35 000 interviews in my career
and
as soon as that camera shuts off
everyone always turns to me and
inevitably in their own way asks this
question
was that okay
i heard it from president bush
i heard it from president obama
i've heard it from heroes and from
housewives i've heard it from victims
and perpetrators of crimes i even heard
it from beyonce and all of her beyonce
she finishes performing hands me the
microphone and says was that okay
friends and family yours enemies
strangers in every argument in every
encounter every exchange i will tell you
they all want to know one thing
was that okay
did you hear me
do you see me
did what i say mean anything to you
and even though this is the college
where facebook was born
my hope is that you will try to go out
and have more face-to-face conversations
with people you may disagree with
[Music]
that you'll have
the the courage
to look them in the eye and hear their
point of view
and
help make sure that the speed and
distance and anonymity of our world
doesn't cause us to lose our ability to
stand in somebody else's shoes
and recognize all that we share as a
people this is imperative for you as an
individual and for our success as a
nation what about something that you
feel like you've personally achieved or
overcome is there something that you are
especially proud of yourself for yeah
i'm
especially proud of myself for not uh
living in the world of comparisons you
know uh years ago when i pulled out that
wagon fat i was actually comparing
myself to everybody else or what i
thought you're supposed to look like or
what size you're supposed to be so i've
now reached the point where i'm really
okay
exactly where i am and that's you know
it's taken me a lifetime practically to
figure that out and being okay exactly
where you are because preparing is a
danger it's so hard because we are in
the world of insta comparison you know
and so
the real spiritual practice is to like
live from within and not let the world
divine who you are but you do that for
yourself that's that's the hardest work
you um are now the ceo of your company
you're the owner and the ceo and you've
got thousands of people working for you
yeah and as a ceo do you have to say no
to people all the time and is that hard
to do uh you get other people who say
that no okay um saying no is hard that
is one of the big big
lessons life lessons for me i i i grew
up obviously girl
uh raised in the south woman need to
please wanting to please everybody so it
took me a long time to get that lesson
of only saying yes to what you intend to
say yes to and and so
i tried to do all of my business
decisions and personal decisions based
upon
my intention many of you
as i have been as i am are where you are
in your life based upon what you believe
and it's not just what you think you
believe on the surface it's also your
shadow beliefs that are holding you back
from moving into the life that you
believe
you deserve
what i know is if you're not looking at
the shadows if you're not looking at
what is subconsciously
running through the tape in your mind
telling yourself you're not good enough
you're not worthy enough you're not
smart enough you're not enough
which is a tape that's playing for a lot
of people
if you're not conscious of that
then you end up acting out of that
belief system and not out of what you
know to be the truest or want to be the
truest for yourself you don't become
what you want because so much of wanting
is about
living in the space of what you don't
have that's why jim carrey's story is so
powerful because he started to act as
though he already had it he would go up
to mulholland drive he would drive away
saying thinking i already have those
things i just haven't accessed them as
yet i believe those things are going to
come to me and i'm going to act like
they are so i'm going to move forward in
my life in order to
draw that to myself in such a way that
my actions are in alignment with what i
say
i believe
so if you start to think about that
really why are you where you are in your
life the choices that you have made
have been because of what you believe to
be true for yourself you wish yourself
they call her auntie gail and me mamo i
said you all wish to have a friend like
auntie gayle
you want to have a friend
who wants
the most the best and the highest for
you i have never seen a person like
gayle i've
never yeah you know everybody especially
if you uh are on the rise in your career
and you have had certain friends and
they all act like they're happy for you
but not everybody's happy for you and
every now and then you can hear just a
teen nazi bit of jealousy you can hear
it you can sense it i've never had a
moment's jealousy from gail in you know
the 30 odd years of her friendship
except
for the one time
i was on stage dancing with tina turner
that's the only time i ever heard gail
goes
i wish that was me
in all of the years of doing the oprah
show
there were many days that i sat in my
chair across from one or two or five or
six or seven people and i would be
so
frustrated
because
i just wanted to shake people sometimes
and say
why
didn't you pay attention
to your life
i said on the show probably the
producers tell me that they counted 33
times but i know i thought it at least a
thousand times i would say
listening to your life
as it whispers to you first so that it
does not have to knock you upside the
head with a brick or come crashing down
on you as a brick wall
is one of the greatest principles of
life because
there are many things that happen in
life that are beyond our control natural
disasters
death
unexplained events but there are also
many many many things in life which we
can control and become out of control
because you're just not paying attention
you are sleepwalking through your life
and i have seen this so many times on
the show i wanted to take the guests and
go would you just pay attention so this
is what i've learned and how i've
explained it to myself
life whispers to you all the time
your life is speaking to you
all around from the time you wake up in
the morning
and every single experience that's
coming into
your
personal space
into your physical space all of those
experiences are speaking to you they're
telling you something about your life
and about your circumstances it whispers
and if you don't get the whisper the
whisper gets louder if you don't get the
whisper when it gets louder it gets i
call it like a little pebble like a
little thump upside your head when i was
a kid if i was doing something my
grandmother didn't like she'd just turn
around and thump me she wouldn't even
look at me she'd just give me a thump
and i'd know that's that's my cue to
stop it or you we're gonna get worse
the whisper is the message the pebble or
the thump upside the head usually it's
gone into a problem you don't pay
attention to the problem the problem
becomes a brick upside your head the
brick upside your head is a crisis you
don't pay attention to the brick upside
your head the crisis turns into a
disaster and the whole house brick wall
comes falling down let me ask all this
have you ever made a complete fool of
yourself over a celebrity
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i have i've never shared this story with
you but today i feel i have to
let it out it was 1973 or four i was uh
19 or 20. i can't quite remember but i
was working in nashville and i had this
obsession i mean obsession
with neil diamond
[Applause]
now
[Applause]
i would wake up
i would wake up in the morning playing
song song blue everybody and i would go
to bed to crackle and rosie and which is
not an easy thing to do in high school
because i could have lost my negro
membership card
you know there were not a lot of negroes
singing crackling rosie but okay so i'm
working in television as this television
station and there was some kind of
benefit and neil diamond was there
because he was performing in town and so
i'm in the green room and i am by the
time 1973 i'm already uh anchor woman on
tv and so i walk into the green room and
there he is and so i say mr diamond
would you like some shrimp
[Applause]
and he said
and he says yes yes i'll take her and he
took her shrimp and i'm like
okay
and then he moved across the room and
then i followed him across the room
that's a big mistake that's the big
mistake people make so i follow him
across the room and so i'm like would
you like another shrimp
and he said yeah i'll take i'll take a
shrimp
he did and then i followed him again
so i'm just staring at him across the
room
and finally i walked up and he goes
enough already
enough already okay so that was my
real
diamond moment i figured this out early
on in the show i had read this quote
from
dr king
one of my favorite quotes from him that
says not everybody can be famous
but everybody could be great because
greatness is determined by service
and i literally shifted i used that
quote to help me shift the way i saw the
platform of television instead of like
oh i'm on tv
how do i use that platform as a platform
of services amen this was what i did
yeah yeah we know and you did that
pretty well too
[Applause]
but when you think about
growing and
being empowered yourself it is what
you've been able to do for other people
that that leaves you the fullest yes
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want some amazing mel robbins motivation
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there if you're
in a situation
where
you should do something and the excuses
roll in
you only have five seconds before the
excuses win